on constitution day president trump
pledges to renew
patriotic education joe biden stumbles
his way through a softball town hall
with cnn
and we may be at the beginning of a
population exodus from blue states i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn surf the web with peace of
mind sign up now at expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so yesterday i i think the
president actually did something
quite important and i understand that
the news cycle is so fast
these days that everybody's attention
span is about half a second long but
what the president did yesterday in
talking about the miseducation of
america's children at the highest level
is really really important it actually
is a very important thing because
the great battle that we are in as a
country is whether the country really
deserves to survive based on the
principles upon which it was founded
there are a lot of people who believe as
i discuss in my new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps there are
people that i call disintegrationists
who believe that america really does not
deserve to survive
based on the philosophy of the
philosophy upon which
she is founded that the principles of
the declaration of independence that
there are inalienable rights that
pre-exist government that are given by
god
or by nature and the government is
instituted to protect those rights
that those principles are bad that basic
principles like freedom of speech
freedom to bear arms freedom of religion
what these really do
is they re-institute and re-inculcate
hierarchies of power
that freedom itself is simply a way of
cementing
current hierarchies of power because
freedom of speech really is mostly
set up because freedom it's set up to
benefit those who are most capable of
taking
advantage of the freedom namely people
who are wealthy or people who have
access to the press
that freedom to bear arms mostly
advantages people who have guns
that freedom of religion mostly
advantages people who want to go to
church and thus if we just got rid of
those freedoms
and we looked for equal outcome instead
this would be a better world this is the
perspective
of much of what they call critical race
theory it is the perspective
of the 1619 project it is the the
proscriptive perspective of so many on
the radical left these days
and they have gained a lot of power i
mean there's no question about this
ever max kennedy is considered a real
thinker in american life today
which is fairly incredible because he
has openly suggested
that the department of that there be at
the federal level
in the executive branch something called
the department of anti-racism this is an
actual suggestion that there'd be
legislation
creating an executive department of
anti-racism at the federal level
that actually has the power to strike
down and rewrite any law in the united
states
federal state or local that does not
achieve equal outcome between racial
groups which is an insane contention
that is fascism okay that is overt
fascism that there is an executive
body that is unanswerable to the people
whose sole job it is
to ensure that all laws achieve equal
outcome
not that they are based on rights in
fact rights must be violated kennedy is
perfectly clear about this he says the
solution to injustice yesterday is
injustice today
and the solution to injustice today will
be injustice tomorrow
and what he means by that is that
people's rights have to be violated to
fix
historic ills and that we have to
recalibrate the entire system
now he's not the first person to make
this contention lbj made this contention
back in the 60s when he suggested
that it was not enough to simply set a
level playing field instead we had to
make sure that everybody was
at the starting line in the same place
what he said is you know there are
people who have been disadvantaged by
american history
and there are certain people who are
starting behind the eight ball we need
to move them
out from behind the eight ball so you
can have an equal race well
that is emotionally compelling but
extraordinarily difficult
to achieve without violating the rights
of individuals
as it turns out the best that we can do
as human beings is to simply
set a level playing field we cannot
redress
all historic wrongs the historic wrongs
that ought to be redressed are the ones
where the person who has harmed another
person
pays the person they have harmed right
that would be normally how you redress
wrongs
but to make somebody who has never
harmed anybody pay historic redress to a
person
who has never been harmed by this person
is actually a violation of rights it is
a wrong
okay well critical race theory teaches
that america was rooted in these
hierarchies of power
and that all of america's philosophies
are designed to cement those hierarchies
of power they're very clear about this
they believe that enlightenment
principles
things like reason things like
individual rights that these are merely
a guise
for reestablishing those hierarchies
derek bell is extremely clear about this
that's what critical race theory is and
it has infused large parts of the
university
the philosophy of the 1619 project which
is that america was rooted in slavery
that all institutions of the united
states are rooted in slavery
and racism and bigotry what that really
is arguing for is that everything that
is good about america is fruit of the
poison is tree and we got to burn it all
down
burn it all down is the underlying
factor that unites these ideologies
and all they have to do is point to the
historic ills of america and say that
wasn't a bug
that was the feature that the system was
designed this way
and because the system was designed this
way we have to destroy the system
and again this has become sort of
in a soft way written into the culture
in a variety of ways when people talk
about systemic racism
what they mean is that all the systems
of the united states are inherently
racist and unfixably racist so you have
to
destroy the system from within this is
why it's always been bizarre to watch
somebody who's an establishmentarian
like joe biden talk about systemic
racism because he never offers any
solutions
systemic racism is merely a formula for
if you give me power i will fix but of
course he has no power to fix systemic
racism because if it's embedded in the
institutions the only solution is to
tear down
the entire institution this is the case
made by
isabel wilkerson in her book cast and
she suggested
that the problem with the united states
is foundational it is not a problem
with structural insecurities in the
walls of the united states
instead it lies right at the foundation
the only way that you can fix that
is to raise the house completely r-a-z-e
raise the house right destroy it and so
this is the philosophy and it is being
taught increasingly across the country
it has it has infused the teaching of
american history
howard zinn obviously a very very
popular historian who's become
in vogue with the jet set glitterati out
here in hollywood which is why he's
name-checked about eight different times
in goodwill hunting howard zinn was a an
actual marxist
who suggested that every good that
america had ever done
was shot through with historic evil
including the victory in world war ii he
actually says in a people's history of
the united states
that the american victory over nazism
was marred by the fact that america
took nazism into its bones took fascist
i mean he says this in his book
america took all of the lessons of the
nazis and integrated them
right it was in america's bones we we
fed off of the evil ideology of the
nazis
america is always and inevitably
historically wrong now
it is true that for many decades in the
united states
there was a willingness to overlook the
dark spots in american history
and that's wrong we shouldn't overlook
the dark spots in american history
i've given entire speeches about this
when i spoke at boston university
last year i i overtly talked
at length about the tremendous horrific
evil of american slavery
and the tremendous horrific evil of jim
crow i talked about the heroism of
people who fought both
the heroism of the leaders of the civil
rights movement and the heroism of
everyday black americans
who fought in defense of the american
flag
that in many cases was still held by
people who
wanted to subjugate them i i end my book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps by telling the story of a member
of the red tails
during world war ii a black american who
came back to a segregated america but
fought on behalf of the constitution and
the declaration of independence
in the skies above germany there's
tremendous heroism
in the american story and there's
tremendous darkness but the heroism
outweighs the darkness
and the philosophy of the united is what
has allowed us to grow
it's what has allowed us to take
universal evils
and destroy them in the united states
see the the way that people who really
don't like the united states think about
the united states
is that all universal human evils are
unique to the united states
and all unique american goods are
universal so this is why you'll see from
the left the idea that the landing on
the moon the moon landing was not an
american achievement it was a human
achievement we got a lot of this
last year when it was the 50th
anniversary of the moon landing it was a
universal human achievement it wasn't an
american achievement it was a human
achievement
the growth and prosperity of the united
states that's not an american
achievement
that's a world achievement that the
natural state of man is to be prosperous
is something nelson mandela once said
idiotically the natural state of man is
to live
life uh life of chaos and privation that
is the natural state of man
it takes civilization to prevent that
from happening we've developed entire
civilizations to prevent all of us from
living in the wild that's that's what
civilization
was designed to do and took thousands of
years of development
to get here the level of ingratitude
toward america that it takes to look at
the things that make america great
our level of freedom our level of
prosperity spreading that freedom and
prosperity to billions of people abroad
over history
and to say well you know that was
universal but what's unique about
america is american slavery it's
historically ignorant
it is wrong-headed and it is designed to
disintegrate the bonds that tie us
together
if the if the thing that makes america
exceptional is american slavery you know
leaving aside the fact
that some 12 million slaves were brought
from africa
to the western hemisphere the vast
majority of whom never saw american
shores most of them actually
ended up in south america and the
caribbean to ignore the fact that
slavery
was an evil human universal for nearly
all of human history up until the last
five minutes or so historically speaking
and then to say that america was unique
in this way but that prosperity was
universal and america is not unique in
that way
you have to be blind or you have to be
motivated to destroy everything
and that's really what is going on here
so unfortunately the 1619 project
is now being taught in a lot of public
schools howard's inn is being assigned
to nearly every college classroom that
i'm aware of
and it's not being taught as a
corrective to whitewashed history that
would be one thing
it would be one thing if you read a
patriotic history of the united states
that sort of
glossed over problems in american
history he said okay and now you should
also read this chapter of howard's inn
that reminds us of all the bad stuff in
american history that's not how this
stuff is taught it is taught as a
replacement
for american history it is an instead of
not in
in addition to the 1619 project openly
stated
this they said that america's true
founding was 1619 not
that america's founding was in 1776 but
we have to take into account the legacy
of 1619
in looking at the history of the united
states that would be fair because
obviously slavery has a lot to do with
the history of the united states that's
not what the 1619 project contended it
contended that the actual founding of
the united states the values upon which
the united states was founded or the
importation of
african slaves to the united states or
to the pre-united states since the us
didn't exist yet
right so the british colonies in in
virginia that that is
an absolute overt lie so yesterday on
constitution day president trump spoke
overtly about this and people lost their
minds
which shows the gap that is a merchant
american public life when i say there's
a gap between people who want to
disintegrate american history and people
who believe in american history
i've never seen it quite as clearly
exposed as what happened yesterday
online after trump suggested that maybe
we ought to teach american
children that america is good people
literally compared him to a nazi
they compared him to vladimir putin they
suggested that when he said that
americans should be taught to be
patriotic about the greatest country in
world history which they should be
that somehow this amounted to jingoistic
nazism
if you believe that teaching american
children that their country
is exceptional and good is a sign of
nazism it's because you are both
historically ignorant and malevolent
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that um unfortunately for me baldness
tends to run in my family male pattern
baldness
um my dad's dad had a lot of hair my
mom's dad no hair at all
and that is why i have been using keeps
two out of three dudes
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left
you just have to go to a doctor's office
for your hair loss prescription now
thanks to keeps you can visit a doctor
online and get hair loss medication
delivered directly to your home
they make it easy they deliver your
medication every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy check out lines
and awkward doctor visits
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there you may have tried them before
probably never for this price keeps
treatments typically take between four
to six months to see results so it's
actually
pretty important to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you will save find out why keeps has
more five star reviews than any of its
competitors and more than a hundred
thousand men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication keeps treatments
started just 10 bucks a month plus for a
limited time you can get your first
month for free
by the way this stuff arrives absolutely
promptly it's exactly the stuff that you
need
and you're going to get it for the
cheapest possible price i know because
again i've been using keeps myself if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com
ben to receive your first month of
treatment for free again that is
keeps.com k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash ben okay so yesterday
president trump gives the speech on
constitution day
in which he says we need to stop
teaching critical race theory and 1619
project nonsense and howard's inn
in our in our public schools and people
just they threw
a bleep fit i mean they just went nuts
over this
now here is the basic rule that i have
when it comes to federal education
i think that the federal government
should not be involved in education i
think the department of education
should be abolished the reason i believe
this is because the same
federal department of education capable
of telling states to teach good history
is similarly capable of telling the
states to teach quite bad history
or to teach common core it seems to me
that education should be devolved to the
lowest level
meaning that you should be able to
control education in your local
community or at the state level
i mean i in an ideal world obviously you
would have community schools that are
directly funded by parents
and by members of the community whether
it's parochial schools or whether it's
private schools or whether it's charter
schools
but in any case if the federal
government is to be involved in the
business of education
certainly it has a stake in people not
learning false history and pseudohistory
and history directly designed to
undermine the foundations of the united
states
because then we lose all commonality so
here was trump going after critical race
theory and the 1619 project
the left is attempting to destroy that
beautiful vision and divide americans by
race
in the service of political power
by viewing every issue through the lens
of race they want to impose a new
segregation and we must not allow that
to happen critical race theory
the 1619 project and the crusade against
american history is
toxic propaganda
ideological poison that if
not removed will dissolve the civic
bonds that
tie us together fact check absolutely
true
i mean someone could write a book about
it oh wait i did how to destroy america
in three easy steps if you want the long
version of trump's speech
with a full chapter on a more accurate
history of the united states and what
that would look like including
all of the dark spots in american
history including the mistreatment of
black americans and mistreatment of
american indians and all the rest okay
he is correct about this this is toxic
stuff
suggesting that america has no
foundational principles which is what
crt says
that all the foundational principles are
basically just a pasteboard fabric
that is designed to obscure deeper evil
attempts to install racial and class
hierarchies
it's disgusting and it destroys the
country and he's exactly right about
this
any country that hopes to survive has to
share a philosophy has to share a
history has to share a culture
crt 1619 project they're aimed directly
at this
now it used to be by the way that um
the the uh nicole hannah jones of the
world would fully admit this
right nicole hannah jones literally
tweeted this out about the 1619 project
back in july quote i've always said the
1619 project is not a history it is a
work of journalism that explicitly seeks
to challenge the national narrative and
therefore the national memory
the project has always been as much
about the present as it is the past in
other words we want to shift how
americans think
about america dramatically right we
don't want to
shade it we don't want to remind them of
bad things we want to completely shift
the narrative
in an incredible i mean she's a radical
it's an incredibly negative thing the
fact that she want to pull us her for a
project that is so bad it was
fact-checked and she refused to change
the fact
she is just she's awful and the fact
that they made her the de facto editor
of the new york times demonstrates where
our media
are at and where the far left are at or
the mainstream left i should say at this
point okay so
trump continued he said it is child
abuse to teach critical race theory to
kids this is 100 true again
teaching a child of any ilk that in a
free country
you are a victim and that you're
inherently a victim because the systems
will victimize you
the systems are out to get you there is
no greater act of viciousness you can
visit upon a child
than teaching a child that no matter how
hard you work you are bound for failure
that is a vicious thing to teach your
child i have three children
last i checked we all live in the united
states my kids are jewish as it turns
out and it turns out that the number one
group in the united states targeted for
hate crimes are jews do you think that
i'm telling my six-year-old that no
matter what you do in the united states
you will not succeed
first of all i can't tell my kids that
cause it's an overt lie
but beyond that it is in it is an act of
deep
abiding immorality to teach people that
they are victims of systems they cannot
see
when especially when that is not true it
turns out that when people are victims
of systems you typically can see it
right jim crow is a system where you can
point out and say you know you're a
victim of the system because they
literally will not allow you to go to
that school across the street because of
your race
that is a fairly obvious situation in
which you're a victim of the system
even in that situation the most
successful people are people who don't
think of themselves as victims
victim being a victim is not is not
being a hero overcoming victimhood is
heroism
reveling in in the fact that there are
obstacles in life is the least likely
thing
to lead you to a successful life and it
happens to be an overly in modern
america
so here is trump saying that crt is
effectively child abuse this is this is
ideologically correct
critical race theory is being forced
into our children's schools
this is offensive and outrageous to
americans of
every ethnicity and it's especially
harmful to
children of minority backgrounds who
should be
uplifted not disparaged
teaching this horrible doctrine to our
children is
a form of child abuse in the truest
sense
of those words okay so trump moves on
and he calls for patriarch patriotic
education this is what drove everybody
nuts the minute you say patriotism
to the left the fact that the word
patriotism is anathema to the left
should tell you something about what the
left believes about the country
do you want to live in a country where
the entire
governing system the people the entire
intelligentsia
believe that being a patriot makes you a
bigot
because that this is what people believe
i am not joking
online as soon as trump said patriotic
education people hitler youth trended
yesterday on twitter
because he said that he thinks that
americans should be patriotic about the
country and that kids should be taught
to be patriotic about the country
hitler youth that's insane
he is not saying that you should be
patriotic about all of america's evils
he's saying you should be patriotic
about america's founding documents about
our ideology about our history
he should be patriotic and recognize the
evils of american history
in the speech he mentioned some of the
evils of american history but the media
deliberately overlooked that
in order to declare that he was some
sort of uber nationalist
deutschland uber alice not it's insane
it's insane
okay we'll get to more of this in just
one one second but first with everything
going on right now you may be wondering
whether you can get life insurance i
mean there are wildfires
and hurricanes and pandemics and riots i
mean it's a good time
out there but you do need life insurance
can you get it you can all you need to
do is head on over to policygenius.com
right now
you could save 1500 bucks or more per
year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for a decade or more those
savings really begin to add up policy
genius is an insurance marketplace built
and backed by a team of industry experts
here's how it works step one
head on over to policy genius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price step two apply for
your lowest price and step three the
policy genius team
handles all the paperwork and the red
tape they handle the rest policy genius
works for you not the insurance
companies if you hit speed bumps they
will handle it for you if you need life
insurance head on over to
policygenius.com right now to get
started you could say 1500 bucks or more
per year
by comparing quotes on their marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and important to get it right
be a responsible human being go get life
insurance right now at the best
competitive price
policygenius.com again that's
policygenius.com
okay so trump yesterday calls for
patriotic education
this should not be controversial of
course americans should believe america
is good
how this is in any way controversial is
absolutely beyond me
it's it it frankly i think that that you
have to be
mentally deficient to believe otherwise
that american children should be taught
that the country that they inhabit is
good
and that it has historically provided
incredible good for the world and that
its founding ideology is good
what you want them taught that america's
evil i mean the answer is yes
that is the actual answer there's a huge
cadre of americans who believe
that children in america should be
taught that the country is evil and must
be torn down to the root
here's trump yesterday the only path
to national unity is through our shared
identity
as americans that is why it is so urgent
that we
finally restore patriotic education to
our schools
today i'm also pleased to announce that
i will soon sign an executive order
establishing a national commission to
promote patriotic education
it will be called the 1776 commission
okay this is not a bad thing so people
went nuts over this
they went totally crazy yamiche alcindor
who's a quote-unquote reporter
over at npr she's not a reporter she's a
propagandist paid for with your tax
dollars over to npr
she tweeted out trump just announced
he'll soon be signing an executive order
establishing a
national commission to promote patriotic
education called the 1776 commission
it is unclear what that means but he has
been trashing the 1619 project which
aims to educate the nation
with facts no the 1619 project is a
pseudo-historical piece of garbage
historians agree on this there are five
separate pulitzer prize winners who went
to the 16-19 project founder and said
you guys are screwing up the facts and
she ignored them
julia jaffe who's an idiot and she
tweeted out you know who else is really
into using the government to promote
patriotic education in schools i feel
like i don't even need to say it anymore
her answer putin putin cause putin
loves patriotic education putin
yes i'm sure vladimir putin also likes
to eat
a hamburger from time to time and
breathe human air and
and drink water like the the hitler also
had a dog argument is getting pretty
weak here guys
how about you argue exactly what you
want taught in american schools because
it turns out that what a lot of these
people want
is not american history taught in an
accurate way with all of the great and
glorious founding ideology of the
founders
not with the full history of the united
states with all of its downs and all of
its ups instead what they want is an
unending litany of america's evils
and the underlying argument being that
all of those evils are a direct result
of america's constitutional governmental
system
and the false principles of the
declaration of independence this is the
argument that is taking place
this is exactly the argument that's
taking place it was amazing
some people i was friendly with i was
tweeting with yesterday online people
getting very angry
at trump over this saying well he's
trump's patriotic education it's just
going to whitewash history i said do you
think that donald trump is actually
going to sit there and write the
curriculum
like really donald trump is going to sit
there and write these same people
who believe that donald trump has no
attention span as an idiot
think that he is simultaneously
developing the vaccine so as to kill
everyone
and also he's going to write the entire
educational curriculum for every young
child across the country
alternatively he will have exactly what
he said he will have a national
commission
that takes a look at educational
standards and says we are not going to
teach
pseudo-historical neo-marxist garbage
about how america is inherently evil
that's a good thing again you want to
make the argument on a systemic level
the federal government should not
control education
i'm with you let's do it i don't think
you want to have that argument i think
what you actually want
is to force the federal government to
sponsor and subsidize your anti-american
bullcrap
adam serwer who writes for the atlantic
sometimes intelligently sometimes not he
he tweeted out yesterday it's it's
political correctness
to say that the federal government
should stop the teaching
of 1619 project or critical race theory
that's political correctness no
it's political correctness to demand
that the federal government subsidize
that stuff if you want to make the
argument
that the federal government should not
be in the business of subsidizing
education and attaching strings
join the libertarian side gang but if
you are arguing that the federal
government
gets to make the rules then of course
the federal government has
somewhat of a stake in ensuring that
people do not learn that would be a good
thing to tear out all the institutions
of the federal government
and by the way they would be right
especially when you're talking about
pseudo-historical nonsense
okay in just a second we're going to get
to what is the greatest troll move
i think i may have ever seen in politics
it's pretty spectacular from the trump
administration then we'll get to joe
biden stumbling and bumbling around a
drive-in stage who thought it was 1965
it was
great for him we'll get to that in just
one second first
let's talk about the fact you are
spending way too much money on your cell
phone bill like a lot too much money why
well a few reasons one you're paying for
all of the middlemen right you go over
to one of these big
cell phone stores and now you're paying
for the storefronts and you're paying
for all the employees and all that
but beyond that you're also paying for
unlimited data which you're probably not
using instead
why don't you just go over to puretalk
puretalk will give you the exact same
coverage same tower same bars
as att verizon t-mobile but it'll cost
you half
no contract no excessive fees right now
you can enjoy
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
all for just 20 bucks a month the
average person is saving 400
a year on their wireless bill so grab
your mobile phone dial pound 250 and say
ben shapiro when you do you save 250
bucks off any iphone including the new
iphone se again that is pound two five
zero
say keyword ben shapiro pure talk usa
simply smarter wireless go check them
out right now you're overpaying your
cell phone bill
why exactly would you not seek to save
400 bucks a year on your wireless bill
and again
you'll save 250 bucks off any iphone
including the new iphone se
when you get involved dial pal two five
zero say keyword ben shapiro to get
started with pure talk usa today okay so
i i will say that calling the left on
their bs
is extraordinarily fun to watch it
really is
so the entire educational system of the
united states higher education
particularly has decided to imbibe
deeply drink deeply
from the narcissistic disassociative
wellspring of critical race theory what
i mean by that is that there are a bunch
of people in higher education who want
to say
yeah america's racist but we're not
we're not them so we will acknowledge
our own racism
we will prove we will do the maoist
struggle sessions where we announce our
own guilt
and that and thus we shall have
alleviated our guilt and we have
reestablished our moral bona fides and
now we get to make the new rules
right we will have expiated our white
guilt and re-established
our moral authority over everyone to
restructure the system from within and
this is why you see all these major
corporations sending out letters
talking about the evils of capitalism
and how america is racist and they're
racist
do they really believe any of that of
course they don't of course there's not
one of these major corporations whose
leadership truly believes that america
is deeply and inherently systemically
racist that their company is deeply
systemically racist or that capitalism
is bad not one of these companies
believes that the nfl does not believe
that the leadership of the nba does not
believe that no
no one believes this this is all cow
towing to a particular narrative so
people will leave them alone
it is so they can buy the allegiance of
the wokesters in the media
and the woke skulls online twitter now
runs the universe okay so
princeton university decided to do this
recently on september 2nd
according to the daily wire hank berrien
reporting the president of princeton
university whose name is christopher
eisgruber
issued a maya culpa in a letter in which
he argued that princeton still events to
racism
writing quote racism and the damage it
does to people of color nevertheless
persist at princeton
as in our society racist assumptions
from the past also remain embedded in
structures of the university itself
right this is the systemic racism
argument i've talked about in a million
times at this point the argument on
systemic racism is not the same as the
argument that racism still exists
of course racism still exists of course
there are still racist
people do racist things that is a
condition that is inherent
to being a human being it just is racism
exists in all societies
at all places at all times if you want
to see truly racist societies against
black people
you might want to take a look at some of
the countries over in europe or in asia
seriously they've done polling data on
people across the world and how
comfortable they would be living with
somebody who's not of their race next
door
and the united states ranks super high
on the list of people who are
comfortable living with somebody of a
different race next door
that's true also for canada and the uk
it is very low other places
okay in any case the argument is not
about racism it's about structures of
racism structural racism
a term institutional racism first coined
by stokely carmichael who later became a
criminal
stokely carmichael made the argument
that
because history matters all of racism is
embedded in structures
and the way that you can tell if a
structure is racist is if the
is if the result of the structure has
racial differentiation
so it's just early stage ibramex candy
and the only way to get rid of that
racism is therefore to tear down the
structures
so this is what princeton means when
they say that racist assumptions from
the past remain embedded in structures
of the university itself
and so they issued this letter right
christopher eisgruber to the entire
princeton community
this is the gr you ready for this this
is the greatest troll of all time
honestly betsy devos deserves a medal as
secretary of education for this
she deserves like the full-on the
full-on
weird face meme from twitter like
engraved in gold
so here's here's what you did on
wednesday the department of education
fired off a letter to princeton
declaring that the university would now
be federally investigated stating it was
quote
concerned princeton's non-discrimination
and equal opportunity assurances in its
program participation agreements from at
least 2013 to the present
may have been false the letter obtained
and published by the washington examiner
continued
based on the fact the secretary of
education may consider measures against
princeton
for false program participation
agreement non-discrimination assurances
including an action to recover funds
also she may consider measures against
princeton for making
substantial misrepresentations about the
nature of its educational program
including a fine proceeding the serious
even shocking nature of princeton's
admissions compel the department to move
with all appropriate speed
the examiner noted that an admission
from ice grouper about the systemic
racism of princeton
raises concerns princeton has been
receiving tens of millions of dollars in
federal funds in violation of title vi
of the civil rights act of 64 which
declares no person in the united states
shall on the ground of race color or
national origin
be excluded from participation in be
denied the benefits of or be subjected
to discrimination
under any program or activity receiving
federal financial assistance
so basically what happened here is the
department of education
is now taking princeton at its word okay
you guys say you're systemically racist
good we're investigating you
you say that all of your institutions
are shot through with racism well you
know that's illegal in the united states
you receive federal dollars so we're
going to look at you and maybe we'll
just take back
our tens of millions so now princeton is
going to be forced to argue
privately to the federal government that
they are not racist but publicly that
they are racist
or that if they are racist it's not
manifesting an actual mistreatment of
black people
it's just kind of out there good call
the bluff
seriously call the bluff i love it if
you're going to go out there
as a as a an entity receiving public
dollars
and claim that you are the result of a
racist system
and that your systems themselves are
racist that's illegal in the united
states it's been illegal for 50 years in
the united states
so all right let's do this thing slow
clap for betsy devos man
department of education this is this is
the only reason i have ever seen for the
department of education
not to be abolished that is that this is
the only reason in history
so good good honestly this is by the way
this should be your tactic in everyday
conversations when someone says
america's systemically racist you should
say to them are you a racist
because they will usually say yes and
you say well i don't talk to racists
and if they say no then you say well if
you're not racist why are you imputing
racism to everybody else
what have i done that's racist what have
you done that's racist if they say well
we are all racist
then you say okay well how do you
expiate your racism and they say well
you admit it
you say yes but now you've admitted
you're a racist so i so why would i why
would i allow to expiate your racism
simply by admitting that you're a racist
you've literally said that racism is
unalterable it is a facet of being white
in america so you can't expect your own
racism and it doesn't matter how many
times
you mimic the slogans of blm and how
many stupid lawn signs you put on your
lawn
it's inherent in your whiteness you can
do a male a struggle
session but the the demands never end
so i'm not going to take you seriously
you shouldn't take anybody seriously who
makes these sorts of contentions or if
you do take them seriously
then go ahead and take them literally
and ask them to prove their own racism
should be a fun conversation okay
meanwhile joe biden got the softball
treatment from cnn who could have
predicted
who could have predicted we'll get that
in just one second first
let's talk about sleep quality so last
night
i go to bed it's like 10 45 feed my baby
i get in bed and i am out like a light
why am i out like a light
because i'm on bullet and branch sheets
bowling branches they're the softest
most comfortable pure organic cotton
sheets on earth
bowling branch cotton it's rain fed
pesticide free it carries the highest
organic certification
that is why it is indeed so soft because
they work with family-owned mills all
over the world to expertly weave every
set of bowl and brand sheets with the
highest levels of craftsmanship it is
quality you can feel the moment you open
the box honestly like i had a bunch of
old sheets i threw out all of them
after i tried bull and branch it ruined
bad sheets for me since they sell direct
to you
bowling brand sheets start at just 160
bucks these are a thousand dollar
quality sheets for a fraction of the
price plus you can sleep on them for a
month
risk free and right now you get 50 bucks
off any sheet set at bulletinbranch.com
with promo code ben shapiro
spelled bollandbranch.com promo code ben
shapiro for 50 bucks off bowl and
branch.com promo code ben shapiro
there's a reason
that millions of americans and three
former u.s presidents sleep on bull and
branch sheets restrictions may apply see
bulletin branch.com
for details is good stuff b-o-l-l and
branch.com
promo code ben shapiro for 50 bucks off
these are fantastic
fantastic sheets okay in just a second
we're gonna get to
joe biden's sterling performance in
which he did not physically fall over
but also did not really say a lot of
sentences that made sense we'll get to
that in just one second
first is that glorious time of the week
when i give a shout out to a daily wire
member today
is amateur mma fighter bang bang sandy
chang on instagram who understands the
need for proper hydration
after a grueling workout in the pick
sandy is donning her purple belt
and g while proudly clutching the
world's finest and most elite
beverage vessel the caption reads i'm
always so thirsty after 7 a.m jiu jitsu
hashtag good morning hashtag leftist
tears tumblr hashtag
america well done my friend thanks for
the pic continued success
in the octagon and yes there is no
question that this person can absolutely
kick my ass by the way
if you're watching on youtube on
september 28th all of my show's content
will be moving to my channel youtube.com
ben shapiro
the link is in the description below
there will still be content on the daily
aware channel but my daily show will be
on my channel so i'm telling you if you
don't want to miss it you need to like
pause what you're doing right now
takes five seconds search ben shapiro on
youtube go to the channel hit the little
bell you're subscribed
we're making room for some new exclusive
content over on daily wire more on that
coming up
but i'm also making a lot of new content
you can only find
on the channel belonging to me so
subscribe to youtube.com
ben shapiro ring the bell make sure you
never miss out on a new
video also i recently sat down with matt
iglesias of vox.com for the sunday
special
this is a great sunday special it's
really fun we discussed a bunch of stuff
ranging from cancel culture
to how you can have cross-aisle
political discussions
one of the things that was really fun
about this is matt and i've been sniping
at each other on twitter for years and
years and years and we still had a
friendly conversation
because it turns out that people can
still have friendly conversations all
they have to do is not be jackasses give
it a listen this sunday if you can't
wait until then
go subscribe at dailywire.com subscribe
and you can watch the episode
a day early take a bit of a listen to
the trailer
this is probably not the ben shapiro
show audience but you know my
progressive friends will want me to
acknowledge
that some bad things happened across the
settling of the west and
all that kind of stuff uh but you know
it was done for a reason and i'm
basically arguing for a
continuation of that kind of vision that
you know the united states
uh is great and should want to be great
and powerful and that that means
having more people
i know actual patriotism from a person
who is a liberal
it turns out that i think again i think
that the the gap in the united states
right now is not even really between
everybody who is kind of left-leaning
and everybody who's right-leaning i
think it's between
liberals and conservatives on the one
hand and wild leftists who want to
destroy the country
on the other and that is their
fundamental ideology okay
well you are listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show
in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so joe biden had a town hall
last night so remember a couple of
nights ago
donald trump had a town hall on abc and
it basically amounted to george
stephanopoulos asking him why he's a bad
orange mean man and then a bunch of
members of the audience who were
undecided
and that they were undecided whether to
vote for bernie sanders as a write-in or
undecided whether to vote for joe biden
that was really like the entire audience
like look at these undecided voters who
have to decide
whether or not to cast a vote for the
marxist party or for the neo-marxist
party
it was amazing so joe biden does a town
hall on cnn
and he has not asked a single really
difficult question during the entire
time
he still manages to sort of bloviate his
way through it
now understand that joe biden's entire
campaign is i'm a nice old codger i mean
that's really what i am just a i'm a
nice old man and
i have caring and empathy and he sort of
falls over
but he hasn't fallen over and that's
really the key to his campaign the
minute he falls over he's got a real
problem on his hands
and i mean let's face it we've had two
presidential candidates
in the last 30 years who have literally
physically fallen over i mean bob dole
fell off a stage in 1996 and then
hillary clinton fell into a van in 2016.
so it could happen i mean it could
happen i'm not hoping for it you want
everybody to remain healthy but joe
biden
is obviously not cognitively with it and
so
you can it's hard honestly it's kind of
hard to watch because just as a human
being you're kind of rooting for him to
finish his sentences
you're rooting for him to somehow come
up with a coach and thought because it's
hard to i mean it's like
watching the office except not funny
right the office the awkwardness is the
funniness
here it's it's actually not funny
because he's kind of like struggling to
get the sentences out and struggling to
get the paragraphs out
and it's really not good but according
to the media it was a
masterful brilliant edifying performance
by joe biden and the reason that it was
brilliant
and wonderful and edifying is of course
because it was in fact joe biden
talking and the fact that he was not
asked like a single difficult question
that's normal according to cnn brian
stelter suggested last night
not kidding brian stelter put in his
newsletter why is it that joe biden is
basically
getting treated with kid gloves his
answer is because donald trump is a big
bad orange mean man
quote of course they are treated
differently the notion that trump should
be interviewed in the same fashion as
biden is absurd
trump has no allegiance to the truth it
shows every single time he's in front of
a camera he lies misleads and promotes
conspiracy theories at an unprecedented
rate in modern american politics
so in other words trump should be asked
difficult questions because trump is a
very bad orange mean man who says things
that i don't like
but joe biden is a wonderful man who
never lies and and has never blowvied
and has never prevaricated never
committed plagiarism
never exaggerated never been insulting
about indian americans
never done anything like okay so the
media have now justified their own
failure of journalism
by suggesting in true journalism fashion
that they really
can't ask questions to jo biden that are
tough because joe biden is just too
wonderful a human being
still joe biden does this town hall last
night and
it gets awkward so for example he was
asked specifically about the green new
deal
he randomly lost his train of thought in
the middle of the answer and talked
about ventilating schools which is a
weird thing to do
there's so much we can do and still
make it better for people we're going to
invest in a
close to a trillion dollars over time in
the near time
for infrastructure we're going to build
green infrastructure
for example i propose that we spend 100
billion dollars
on making sure our schools have the
right
the the the right ventilation making
sure schools in fact
are safe making sure schools are in a
position where they are not
generating the use of more energy okay
so he loses track in the middle
obviously and then he realizes oh wait
this is a question about the green new
deal
i probably need to ventilating schools
making them safer that's a coveted thing
that's not a green new deal thing
he just loses track in the middle and
there's a lot of us
he was asked by a woman who was a farmer
about over-regulation
his answer was something having to do
with
chicken bleep in delaware not kidding it
was
literally he gave an answer about
chicken manure
in delaware and the lady is staring at
him like i don't
know what you're talking about joe
here was here's the here's the question
and answer unbelievable
in the united states in my state of
delaware we have
a four billion dollar industry chickens
chicken and chicken and poultry and all
what is all the
all the manure quite frankly that is a
consequence of
chickens and so it's polluting the
chesapeake bay
but we found out we've invested a lot of
money we found out you can pelletize
this
and take out take out the the methane so
you're in a position where
you can use that fertilizer without the
damage that was being done before
the same way with horse manure and cow
manure and pig manure
he is definitely an expert in types of
manure and slinging them around
uh that lady's expression they just need
to close in on her face
and then go directly to the curb your
enthusiasm credits because she's like
what in the f i was just asking about
like please don't shut down my farm
through your crappy over-regulation and
your green new deal nonsense and he's
like
let me tell you about this time i saw on
the side of the road
let me just tell you about this time
where i saw like there was poop
and i don't know whether it was like
from a beaver or a dolphin
but it was on the side of the road and i
picked it up and i said to corn pop
why is there poop in my leg hair
why everybody's like
joe biden look at that performance that
man is gonna be
our president for 32.7 seconds before
kamala harris is the president of the
united states
joe biden also unleashed a bit of
radicalism that the media immediately
covered up so he said he backed the
green new deal but then he backed off it
right this is the way that joe biden
does it
he has asked specifically about the
radical policies of his own party and
then he says he backs them but i've also
provided an alternative plan that's not
quite as radical
and that way when republicans say he
backs the green new deal the media
fact-checked them they say ah but he
also said
that he has his own plan okay you can't
have it both ways if you back the green
new deal you want 93 trillion dollars
in new spending trillion with a t
but watch joe biden split the baby here
she was asking a green new deal do you
back that or do you think it's too much
no i don't think it's pretty much not i
have my own deal i've laid it out in
great detail
once the democratic party's adopted as a
platform it requires for us to move in a
direction
to fundamentally change the way in which
we deal
with the environment okay and then
he uh was asked about china and he was
repeatedly asked whether he'd call china
an opponent
he would not so you know the the fact
that joe biden says that
again you want to talk about media
malfeasance the intelligence community
came up with a report
it said the russians would try to
interfere in the election again and they
would do so on behalf of trump
they also said iran and china would
attempt to interfere with the election
on behalf of joe biden
which one of those things have you heard
from mainstream media infinitely
right trump won in 2016 because of the
russians not true trump won in 20
trump if he wins it'll be because of the
russians in 2020.
which country is more powerful and has
more propagandistic arms in the united
states
the chinese government or the russian
government there's no question and the
chinese government
is apparently attempting to interfere on
biden's behalf but you never hear about
it
here is joe biden saying that he won't
call the chinese and opponent they're
they're more like a competitor you know
they're not really an opponent
even though they're actively engaging in
human rights abuses they're actively
subjecting
formerly free states like hong kong to
to abject tyranny
they are they're clearly attempting
aggressive action in the south china sea
directed at japan and taiwan
they're creating a belt and road program
designed to minimize western influence
and to maximize their own but joe biden
won't call them an opponent no matter
what but
don't worry he's going to be strong on
china guys
do you view china as an opponent because
the the president says you've been too
cozy with china
too accepting of them in the
international community i i'm not the
guy
look china we now have a larger trade
deficit with china than we've ever had
with china
and in our administration when the world
trade organization he keeps going on
about
just rule that his his trade policy
violated the world trade organization
we sued we went to the world trade
organization 16 times
do you view china as an opponent i
viewed kind as a competitor
oh competitor is it a competitor and
then of course he fights on fracking
because he doesn't want to lose
pennsylvania but also he has pledged to
basically
end fracking he says no new licenses
which of course means pretty quickly the
end of fracking
here was joe biden trying to split the
baby once again
you said you you won't ban fracking but
did you wanted to gradually move away
from it
ultimately um it sounds like
to some you're trying to have it both
ways well fracking has to continue
because we need to transition
we're going to get to net zero emissions
by 2050
and we'll get to net zero power
admissions
by 2035 but there's no rationale
to eliminate right now fracking
okay so no don't worry we're not gonna
we're not gonna get rid of your fracking
job right now
we're just gonna make sure that nobody
can ever get a new fracking job and then
we're gonna regulate it out of existence
now
the truth is that joe biden's campaign
really relies on two things one
orange man bad and the other is orange
man responsible for everybody dying from
covid
and this is the case where biden is is
going to have
the strongest case mainly because he's
not in power
see the thing about being in power when
there's a massive pandemic is that
pretty much
every everybody gets she'll act or at
least they should be if the media
weren't completely full of it
right apparently andrew cuomo escapes
all censure despite the fact that his
state got
just reamed apparently the governor of
new jersey gets away with it even though
his state got absolutely creamed
but bottom line is that you can blame
trump for everything and that's what
biden proceeded to do last night
he said that uh the virus is costing us
our freedoms well actually right now
it's lockdowns that are costing us our
freedoms not the virus itself
because if people wore masks in public
places and they're young and they're not
sick we could all be back at work right
now and in fact that is what we should
be pursuing
in fact that is what most places in
europe are pursuing right now but
according to joe biden it's only the
virus
the virus is the only reason why we're
locked down not actual formal lockdowns
in many many states
including california where literally
half of the unemployed now live
i would tell you what takes away your
freedom what takes away your freedom is
not being able to
see your kid not being able to go to the
football game or baseball game
not be able to see your mom or dad sick
in the hospital not being able to do the
things that's what caused our freedom
and it's been the failure of this
president to deal
to deal with this virus and he knew
about it he knew the detail of it
he knew it in clear term imagine had he
at the state of the union stood up and
said
when back in january i wrote an article
for usa today saying
we've got a pen that we got a real
problem imagine if he had said something
okay well you know you wrote that
editorial in usa today joe in which you
said coronavirus could be bad
then you proceeded to hold in-person
rallies up until the first week of march
march at no point did you call for
universal masking in february at no
point did you call for lockdowns
in february at no point did anybody do
any of that stuff this revisionist
history whereby democrats just don't
exist in the narrative
is truly incredible joe biden actually
made the claim yesterday that if trump
had done his job
every single human being who has died
from covert would still be alive that is
patently nuts
i mean like there is no evidence this is
the case at all
if the president had done his job had
done his job from the beginning
all the people would still be alive
all the people i'm not making this up
just look at the data
look at the data you are making that up
there is no evidence that that is the
case
none if the president had done his job
since the beginning you held rallies
until march at doof
okay but of course again it's very easy
to sit outside because
when a bad thing happens and the person
in power is in power you can easily
blame them and if you're the media you
just go right along with it then of
course
joe biden jumped on william barr so
william barr is the attorney general of
course
and uh yesterday bar gave a speech
talking about at hillsdale college
talking about the doj and in the middle
of his q a he was talking about the
coveted lockdowns and he said they were
radical intrusion
unlimited so let's actually play the
clip of bill barr so you get the full
context as to what he's saying here
they had home orders is like house
arrest it's not
it's it's you know other than slavery
which was a different kind of restraint
this is the greatest intrusion on civil
liberties in american history
we have epidemics and pandemics this is
a very serious one a grave one
but uh they they come and and
you know just because something is a
medical crisis it doesn't give a
complete blank check
to to executive rule so is the slavery
reference that of course
he's getting hit over he was not
comparing the moral quandary of slavery
and the moral evil of slavery to the
morality of lockdown to idiots he's
explicitly
denouncing that he's explicitly taking
that and saying slavery to the side
which is a whole different issue because
of its inherent moral evil
right that that putting that issue aside
if you're just talking about
restrictions on daily movement by
americans
this is the greatest restriction on
daily movement by americans in american
history
which by the numbers is essentially true
he's explicitly saying
it's not like slavery and so the media
go well he's comparing it to slavery and
then they ask joe biden
and he's like joe what are you here
here's a brick would you like to hit
william bar with it and joe's like well
i can't swing it very hard and i can't
lift it very high but but i guess
all right he's sick he's a bad man
do you think the comments by the
attorney general
contribute to people i mean encourage
people not to wear masks
i mean quite frankly they're sick think
about it
did you ever ever think any of you you'd
hear
attorney general say that following the
recommendations of the scientific
community
to save your and other people's lives is
equivalent
to slavery people being put in chains
you lost your freedom because he didn't
act
i have a question in that sentence he
said you lost your freedom because you
didn't act
you lost your freedom he's saying that
it's a restriction
you lost your you lost your freedom
seems like a restriction on liberty
also he deliberately did not compare it
to slavery he explicitly took slavery
and put it to the side
and so joe biden who apparently doesn't
speak english or is wildly dishonest or
both
he's like no he was comparing its
slavery he was absolutely 100 not
comparing it to slavery
if i say to you that other than this
thing
this is a really bad thing here like
other than
here's a really bad thing that's
happening and other than this much worse
and very different thing
this is a very bad thing that is not me
saying the two things are equivalent is
me deliberately disassociating the two
things you morons
okay but again joe biden he was treated
with kid gloves by the way politico
politico put out an actual tweet in in
which
they admitted this right here is
politico's tweet if abc's event with
president trump was an icy grilling
cnn's driving conversation with joe
biden yesterday was more like an affable
reunion of old acquaintances
yeah no bleep yeah that is pretty damned
obvious
affable acquaintance between old old
friends yeah i got that i got that cnn
the most trusted name
in news meanwhile i do love the the
democratic take on kovid which again is
the the focal point of their campaign
their take is vaccines are bad if
they're developed under the trump
administration
also republican governors are extremely
bad also blue governors are extremely
good
and if you distinguish between red and
blue and you're a republican you are
also extremely bad
so that is the line right here so the
the pro science crew here was joe biden
yesterday saying
that he doesn't trust trump on the
vaccine no one's asking you to trust
trump on the vaccine
trump ain't the one handing out the
vaccine or developing the vaccine you
know what we're asking you to do
trust all of the departments inside the
federal government
who's ab who's absolute test do you
trust redfield you trust fauci you trust
berks do you trust do you trust the
doctors who you've been
lighting votive candles to for months at
this point here's joe biden talking down
vaccines
it's amazing this is this is the party
that says that they are all in favor of
the science
and all in favor of ending the problems
of
covet as soon as possible talking down
one of the chief ways we're going to end
that problem which is the development of
a vaccine
first of all i don't trust the president
on vaccines i trust dr fauci
if fausti says the vaccine is safe i
take the vaccine that we should listen
to the scientists not to the president
okay um so who do you think is going to
be making the next but
here's the problem when you say you
don't trust the vaccine as long as trump
is in office what you really mean is you
don't trust the vaccine until trump
is is out of office right because your
implication is that trump is pressuring
the scientists
to botch this thing meanwhile democrats
went nuts yesterday because
trump during oppressor he pointed out
that if you don't count the blue states
and how they've handled this thing
that the numbers are actually a lot
better now
that's true it's not supremely helpful
right because again nobody really knew
how to deal with the pandemic very well
in the beginning
the only real activity you can fault
people for is what should have been
obvious from the beginning which is
protect the
people in nursing homes protect the
elderly protect the vulnerable which
everybody failed to do in new york new
jersey michigan et cetera
but let's be real about this the
division between red states and blue
states on covet has been pushed by the
media and pushed by the democrats since
the very beginning
ron desantis was evil for not shutting
down jacksonville beaches
doug ducey was evil for not for not
fully shutting down the economy of
arizona
kirsty gnome in south dakota is still
evil for not having shut down south
dakota which by the way currently has a
4.8
unemployment rate and not tons of death
so it was democrats who decided to make
this a red blue issue i've said since
the beginning i don't understand why
there should be a red blue issue
you should actually follow the best
scientific procedures and then you
should alleviate lockdown when it
appears that lockdown
is no longer achieving what it was
originally supposed to achieve namely
avoiding the overwhelm of the hospitals
i am the one
who's been saying since the beginning
that you should follow the actual
recommendations
of people who are who are examining the
data
it was democrats who immediately went to
red states are mishandling this and blue
states
they were saying that while ronda
sanders had no cases in florida
okay but meanwhile democrats are very
angry that trump mentioned the
difference between red states and blue
states in terms of deaths per million by
the way out of the top 11 places in the
united states including dc
deaths per million i believe eight of
them are blue just for the record here
is chuck schumer saying that trump is
monstrous and demented for
distinguishing blue states which is
weird
because i'm old enough to remember when
the democrats were saying that all the
red states were monstrous and demented
for even opening
the atlantic ran a headline about
georgia saying that it was brian kemp's
experiment in human sacrifice to reopen
georgia
here is chuck schumer what kind of
person
looks at the number of dead citizens in
the country he is supposed to lead
and an attempt to glamorize himself
dismisses every american who died in a
state
that didn't support the president
politically what a disgrace
it's monstrous not a shred of empathy
what kind of demented person would say
that those american lives don't count
no one said the american lives don't
count no one did that i mean if anybody
has degraded american lives in places
like new york by the way
it was andrew cuomo who built a paper
mache mountain of death as tribute to
himself
to show how wonderfully he had handled
he made a poster to himself
with a curve showing dead people
making light of death and also do you
remember the dnc it wasn't that long ago
they literally took a woman whose dad
died of covid
and voted for trump and said he was an
idiot and it was his own fault he died
because he listened to donald trump
they degraded the value of every trump
supporter who had died of code by
basically saying they brought it on
himself
meanwhile james clyburn makes a
completely unbased accusation
saying that trump refused to act on
covet because it was hitting blue states
like i'm gonna need some evidence that
it was specifically
because trump hates the blue states that
he was not acting on code by the way he
gave all the ventilators that new york
needed
to new york gavin newsom said he gave us
all the resources we needed jay inslee
in washington said he gave us all the
resources
we needed but here is james clyburn
suggesting that trump
just allowed people in blue states to
die oh well
if you say so james
back in april the administration
considered
implementing a national strategy but
decided not to do so because at the time
the virus
was primarily spreading in blue states
just yesterday we saw the president
still employing this political strategy
boasting that there would be fewer
deaths
and i'm quoting him here if you take the
blue states
out okay again the reason that they
didn't implement a national strategy
is because america is a nation with lots
of states and not all the states were
being hit equivalently
and so a national strategy would have
forced states that were not being hit
to shut down which would have been very
silly you should not shut down states
that don't have any cases
okay now this doesn't mean that the
white house handled everything with
regard to covet properly
there's a story yesterday that i think
actually is is probably the most
damaging story that i've seen
on the trump administration's handling
of covet this is from business insider
talking about how the white house
scuttled a plan to partner with the us
postal service to send every american
a face mask the washington post found a
draft a draft press release showing the
postal service was preparing to send out
650 million face masks in april
to supply every household with them that
would have been a good idea by the way
that would have been a very good idea
because i've always been very baffled by
the
sort of conservative notion that in
order to reopen we have to take off the
mask it was sort of the opposite if you
want to reopen then people should have
been wearing masks
i've been saying that since the
beginning do the social distancing and
where the master we can reopen
and get back to normal and then the
virus slowly works its way through the
community and then you're done
and in fact that's kind of what happened
in places like florida and arizona and
texas and georgia
if the masking rate went up as the virus
went up so that was a mistake
obviously and mistakes clearly were made
by the trump administration
but again the the notion that democrats
would have handled this tons better i'm
i'm waiting to see any evidence of that
at all at all at all at all
okay so i do want to make a quick note
here
that uh tonight is rosh hashanah so rosh
hashanah is the beginning of the
jewish new year and so i want to talk
for just a minute
about rosh hashanah because it is a very
meaningful time in
jewish life and frankly i think it has
some some things to teach everybody
about the nature of the universe in
which we live so
the jewish new year happens starting
tonight it carries on
for two days it's sort of different from
the american new year or the world new
year and that
during the american new year your drink
and you're married and then you sort of
make resolutions for the new year
the jewish new year is about two things
it's about celebrating god's creation of
the universe and it's about leading off
what are called the asceriamate
which are the the 10 days of repentance
so you have 10 days to sort of get your
life straight before yom kippur which is
the day of repentance
which i'll be taking off a day in 10
days
uh to to fast and pray for repentance
and and the idea here is that you have
basically
on the repentant side you have 10 days
to sort of demonstrate to god that you
would like to fix
your problems and you know it's a
beautiful idea but
the the we'll get to maybe i'll talk
about yom kippur on near yom kippur but
when it comes to rosh hashanah the
create
the idea of god's creation of the
universe being celebrated the bria as
it's called
in hebrew at the beginning of genesis
that that in the beginning
god created the heavens and the earth
why is that an important idea
well it's an important idea for a
variety of reasons first of all
it means that man is central to the
universe that doesn't mean that we are
literally living at the center of the
universe as pre-copernican theory sort
of suggested
it doesn't mean that man is completely
disconnected from the animal world
what it does mean is that human beings
create meaning in the universe this is
why when people say you know that the
earth would be better off without us
what is the earth care they
the earth has no sentience what does it
matter whether the trees feel better
without human beings
human beings are meaning creating
creatures and thus
meaning in the universe springs into
existence with the creation of sentient
human beings
so god's creation of the universe in
that way the universe was made
for man to provide meaning in the
universe and so god's creation
of man lends meaning to to
the entire creation itself
god's creation of the universe
culminates with man see there's
something beautiful about
the biblical story of creation it does
two things one
it reminds human beings that they are
nothing and two it reminds human beings
that they are everything
it reminds human beings that they are
created from the earth and back to the
earth they will return
they are human beings in the creation
story in genesis are created on the
sixth day of creation they don't have
their own separate day of creation right
the
god creates the animals and creates
human beings at the very end of the
sixth day
meaning that we are innately wrapped up
in our own animal instincts but we have
the capacity to look up to the stars
meaning rests in us and if we fail to
take advantage of that meaning then we
are degraded to the level
of animals the the importance of god
creation
and we should be grateful for the fact
that god created the universe the way
that he did we should be grateful for
this universe which is not always easy
to be i mean it's a tough universe to
live in sometimes
but we should be very grateful for the
fact that god fine-tuned the universe
this is the the argument that religious
people often make
for the existence of god and trying to
evidence god in the universe is that the
conditions had to be incredibly precise
in order for human beings to arise in
fact there was a recent study
showing that of 10 million stars that
have been surveyed that we've seen
essentially no signs of any other form
of anything like sentient
human beings or sentient creatures
literally anywhere
the conditions for the creation of life
have to be extraordinarily precise
atheists will say well you know if you
run the same game over and over and over
then eventually you come up with life
and and so they posit things like
multiple universe theory there's tons of
universes an infinite number of
universes actually
and so if they're an infinite number of
universes then every possibility is
possible
in every universe the evidence for
multiple universes is zero because you
can't get outside your own universe to
actually examine whether there are
multiple universes
which means that that's an act of faith
as well the fine-tuning of the universe
for human life
is indeed proof that something wants
something wants us to be here and that
is something that is worth noting
now the the counter argument is that you
know if you're the one guy who wins the
lottery then you think that the lottery
picked you out
okay but that assumes that there's a
winner in the lottery there didn't have
to be a winner in the lottery
whenever there's a lottery you assume
there will be one winner it just happens
to be you this time
but in this universe there's no reason
why there has to be life
it could be a coincidence when you have
this many things lining up this way
uh it tends toward the conclusion that
it is not
now put aside sort of the religious
arguments for a second what is the value
of believing on a human level
that god created the universe a few
things one
if you are a scientifically minded
person then you tend to believe that the
universe operates by understandable
rules you also tend to believe in things
like objective truth
that outside of you there is a truth
then not all truth is about your
subjective perception of the truth
and that your mind can grasp these
truths
there's nothing in simple materialism
that suggests any of these things
objective truth does not exist in a
world of pure materialism you're simply
an evolved creature
who is capable of adapting to your
environment that doesn't mean that the
way you adapt is true
it means that you adapt in the most
adaptable way
but if you believe there is such thing
as objective truth you have to explain
why there is such a thing as objective
truth outside of you
why are there rules that we as human
beings very very limited creatures can
actually understand
and utilize to our advantage and it's
not just that we are utilizing them to
our advantage
in ways that are sort of practical it's
that we can understand
objectively true things how do you
believe in an objective truth
if you don't believe that there's
anything setting that objective truth
adaptability and environmental
adaptation
do not equal objective truth so the idea
that god created the universe with
certain
understandable rules leads inevitably to
the idea
that the human being has the capacity to
understand
many of those rules so it leads to the
impetus for science because science is
about the investigation of those
objective rules and objective truths
it suggests discernible rules in the
universe and on a human level
it also suggests that human beings have
incredible worth
right the biblical account of creation
i've said this before the single most
important verse in the bible is that god
created human beings in his image
it doesn't mean that god looks like
human beings what it means is that god
created us with the ability to reason
god created us with the ability to
create and that we owe each other
recognition that we are each made in
god's image
you can't enslave somebody if you
believe that they are made in the image
of god
you can't mistreat somebody if you
believe that they are made in the image
of god
enlightenment values of individualism
and individual rights spring directly
from the idea that you are made in the
image of god because on a pure
materialistic level who cares you're
just
you're just a ball of meat wandering
through the universe so the idea of
god's creation
lends weight to the to the
statements of the declaration of
independence which is of course why
jefferson
who had a a sort of complicated
relationship with organized religion at
the very best
suggests that our rights lie inevitably
in in a creator or nature
now what that means in the end and this
is how it connects to to the 10 days of
repentance
is that we do have responsibilities to
the one who created us just like you
have responsibilities to your parents if
responsibilities to the one who created
us
who give us a mind to comprehend the
universe around us he did that so that
we could seek truth and act morally
god created us with the moral sense
right this is the contin statement that
the best evidence
of god is the starry heavens above and
the moral sense within
we have the capacity to understand the
universe we have the capacity to intuit
moral laws from looking at the universe
around us
as the idea of natural law which
inevitably well not inevitably
eventually gives rise to the idea of
natural rights that rights lie within
you
the birth of the enlightenment the birth
of science the birth of all the things
that you believe in whether you're a
secular humanist living in the united
states or whether you're a religious
person
lie in the basic idea that god created
the universe and that's what we're
celebrating here on rosh hashanah
so with that said shana tova um meaning
a sweet
and happy new year to you and we'll see
you here a little bit later today for a
couple additional hours or we'll see you
here
next week i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
hope you'll give it a listen